walk him to this video playing satellite
from Canada went for a modern modern
defense yeah how to play this can i play
for me 5m yeah this is not to inspiring
just taking it okay so
hmm not quite sure
what yeah it's it's fairly solid of
course phone provide
hmm i see now you also play 3221 and
somehow try to wait that's not blunder
something okay I need to get rid of the
knight c6 is the move but I want to
prevent a4 a5 first
okay so
so at the end oh nothing much happened
why does some probably a bit more
comfortable I have the bishops but of
course it's not not so easy to do
something at the moment with them okay I
guess just we should be same loop the
eight bishops yet this kind of this kind
of regrouping hmm yeah if 7s hanging at
the end of it is some it is slightly
clocked up here hmm how to how to stool
to improve the pieces
okay what do you want to go to see eight
with the bishop so that at least I have
my my rooks somehow in plane and now i
need to regroup here maybe mmm like
bishop i have six king g 7i g8 or
something yeah white is so enjoying a
good good game of the site don't really
understand Bishop f6 don't you need to
retreat them where do you go and I
wanted to play this anyway
yep he wants to go to g4 and I want to
prevent it so nigh g8 sort of slowly
sword in this position and now group t8
getting the rooks off and when the ropes
are exchanged the position immediately
turns into into okay for black how to
continue now it's not like I'm not
better but I've got the two bishops so
there's something to to play for
how to regroup though let's um let's
start with that
stetson rabbit this doesn't really
happen this doesn't really have a
specific idea immediately okay so it had
it had an idea they provoked you for
which isn't exactly clear if it was
helpful for him I'm attending Bishop g5
now activating the Bishop g5 to f4 would
be excellent if you don't manage that
yeah he cannot take on g5 and f7 because
of Queen f4
hmm yeah I think he's getting getting a
bit outplayed now this looks so good now
for me I'm also just threatening to take
a plane Knight f6 act attacking efore g4
and his king is also in bad shape as
always this a 4 check okay so i can get
this your first is check and now this is
a text still be 4g phone I don't see how
to protect it yeah I can take a corner
and g5 has gone as well yeah g4 was was
bad I summer i provoked this move but
I'm not intentionally
ok it still needs to be a v1 but we
carefully bishop Adriatic he needs to
take on g5 I don't really Jesse
something else
yeah Kiev one how to do this now I can
also wait if I take twice on III am
threatening Bishop h3 made and this is
really this is very hard to hard to
prevent quite resigned yeah yeah he
played this really nicely I think but
then g4 was was real lemon without that
it's probably probably about equal but I
needed to defend really precisely here
and maybe he had something it's it's
it's very very possible after the rooks
off I'm I'm the one to do something
because of the bishops is this son this
is just weakening weakening the old
position yeah and this is gone now this
is just too too weak I will moving
material here and have a king king
attack on top of that alright thanks for
watching